こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
あの～
毎年多分春ぐらいかな
春ってなんかこうフワフワしてるっていうか
あったかくなってくるから多分
頭おかしい人が増えるんですよ
ε- (´ー`*)ﾌｯ
人の事言えねぇな
でなんかツイッターでよく変な人がいると思うんですけども
今回特に変な人が
えー
大量発生しております
例えば僕のツイートがあるじゃないですか
多分直ぐいますよ
あっ
もう直ぐいました
はい、こちら
トマト
この何かねトマトって言うアカウントがめちゃくちゃ多いんですよ最近
で最近ちょっと余りに多すぎたんで
ちょっとトマトって言うつぶやきをしたぐらいです
ここらへんとかめっちゃ多いですね
トマト(イエローミニ)
トマト(白)
土浦産トマト
ニュートマト
この子達もう何かあるたびに直ぐトマトって僕にリプ送ってくるんですよ
白いトマトもトマト！！！って言ってますし
これはトマトレインボーですね
きっと位の高いトマトなんだと思います
こいつとかヤバいっすね
もうずっとトマトトマト言ってます
実に怪しい
ほらヤバいもうヤバい
トマトトマトトマトトマト
『すいません』
謝ってますね
いやぁもうヤバい
マジでトマトしか言ってねぇこれは
凄いですね
本当にトマトなのかもしれない
疑うぐらいものすごいトマトです
黄色トマトもいますね
アボカドもいますね
いやぁもう謎の猫と謎の犬に挟まれてる辺りがどうも
そこら辺の界隈の方達なのかなという
気がしております
というわけで今日の動画は
ちょっと本当に意味不明です
僕が何つぶやいても絶対もうリプの最初にトマトトマトって埋まってるんで
僕はもう恐怖を覚えているわけですよ
中にどんな人がやって
何の目的でやっているのか
今日は暴いていこうと思います
多分こいつが戦犯だな
多分このトマトが戦犯ですね
＠yasainoTomato
絶対こいつです
早速DMでアタックしてみます
まずは軽くジャブですね
『こんにちは』
もう色んなトマトにとりあえずちょっとアピールしてみましょう
黄トマトにもやってみます
『こんにちは』
トマトのイエローミニですね
きっと小さい品種なんでしょう
『こんばんは』
トマトブラック
おぉー
黒いトマトですね
『こんばんは』
未成熟の緑のトマトですね
出荷が赤くなるまで待ってるみたいです(？)
このトマトは
あぁー
不作でした
不作のトマトもいるみたいですね
はいというわけで僕のツイッターが
トマトで埋まってしまいました
今んとこ反応があるのは
イエローミニが反応してますね
『好きなトマト料理教えてください』
えぇー俺トマトあんま好きじゃねぇんだよなぁ
早っもう◎△＄♪×￥●＆％＃？！
いやここぞと強気でいきましょう
『貴様に質問がある答えよ』
わぁすげー気付いた
黄色トマトとトマトレインボー
紫トマトから返ってきてます
紫はとりあえずちょっとご機嫌を伺っておきましょう
『何者なのだ』
『貴様は』
『答えよ！！！！！！』
わっニュートマトが何か言ってますね次は
『幻聴か・・・』
黄色トマト『こんにちは』
元気が良いですね
あぁ紫トマトは眠いらしいですね
あらま。。。トマトも大変そうですね
『荒手の嫌がらせか・・・』
やべニュートマトが僕のことアンチと思ってますね
とりあえずもうお前らが何なのかを知りたいですね
すげぇめちゃくちゃトマト喋るやん
トマトブラックとグリーントマトとトマトの種は
ちょっとまだ沈黙を貫いております
本家のトマトはまだ何も喋ってないっすね
だめだちょっと掴めねぇな
ちょっと皆さんに共通の質問をしてみましょう
よし攻めるぞ
あなたは何者なんですか
もうとりあえずストレートに聞いてみましょう
あぁーレインボートマトは『こわいよー』って言ってますね
ちょっと僕が聞いてきたから多分恐怖心を覚えてしまったんだ
レインボートマトはこうちょっとおだてて
僕が怖くない人だよっていうのを教えてあげましょう
ふざけとんのかお前は！！！
白トマトはもうダメですね
こいつはもうトマトになりきっています
ちょっと年齢とか聞いてみよう
年齢ちょっと気になりますね
あぁー
ニュートマトはちょっと返事に迷ってますね
この子恥ずかしがり屋ｋ
おっとここで返事がきた！
ん？
『はじめしゃちょーの大ファンのクソトマトだす』
やっぱはじめしゃちょー僕の動画を観てるっていうのは認めているみたいですね
だからリプよく送ってくれるのかなぁ？
えーっとイエローミニは
『トマトをみんなに好きになってもらおうと活動しているトマトです』
あぁー
あくまでトマトでいくパターンかぁ
なんなのこいつら掴めねぇなマジで
おっ何か言おうとしてる
ニュートマトがストーカーの心配してくれてます
ヤバいレインボートマトがついに目的を聞いてきましたね
こいつは警戒心が高くなってきています危ない
『むらしゃきのやつだよー』
『とめいとー』
紫はもうダメですね
んぁ？
何だ
キラートマトやないかい！！！！！
だめだこいつら何も教えてくれねぇマジで
ちょっと最後に質問で色んなトマトいるんですよ本当に
白トマトとか黒トマトとか色々いるんですけど
皆さんの関係性をちょっと聞いてみましょう
おいふざけんじゃねぇぞ
何が雨上がり決死隊のトーク番組
トマトーークじゃ
馬鹿にしとんのかぁ！！！
あの僕にリプするとその
皆が見ちゃうから
それでトマト好きを増やそうとしてるらしいですね
おぉー
『トマト仲間で、数週間前に出会っトマト』
駄目だ本当に分かんねぇ
ニュートマトさんは結構優しめですね
あぁー
トマト畑っていうグループができてるみたいですね
(笑)
うーんイエローミニトマトからしたら家族みたいなものらしいですね
何言ってんだよおめぇ
♪ BGM ♪
Thank you for watching!
Please share with SNS! (Twitter Google+ Facebook .etc..)
ペー　ぺぺぺぺーぺー　ぺぺぺぺー　ぺぺぺぺーぺー　ぺぺぺぺー　ぺーぺぺ
ぺぺぺぺーぺーぺーーーー
Please subscribe!
ペー　ぺぺぺぺーぺー　ぺぺぺぺー　ぺぺぺぺーぺー　ぺぺぺぺー　ぺーぺぺ
ぺぺぺぺーぺーぺーーーー
ぺっぺっぺっぺ☆
はいというわけでちょっと色んなトマトに話しまくってみたんですけども
全く掴めませんでした
もう謎は深まるばかりでございます
野菜にフォーカスを合わせて攻めてくるタイプは初めてだったんで
ちょっと
びっくりしました
まぁけど何か
トマトさん皆
あの動画観て応援してくれてるみたいなんで
まぁ
良かったです
ただ心残りなのは本当にねぇ
何も分かんなかったこの人達の
あのぉ
中身が
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
また会おう...